alright guys I've got Michael here from
from air swap and fluidity I'm super
excited about this we've got a bunch too
to dig through so thank you very much
for coming thank you pop thank you for
having me absolutely all right so let's
start with your background I think
everyone knows the crypto side but you
actually have been in finance and
trading all suffer for quite a while
yeah so math at Carnegie Mellon
undergrad and then I joined the small
trading company called virtue financial
grew like crazy brought it out through
you know their Asia expansion and I made
partner like when I was 25 which is
probably the coolest thing that's ever
happened me I went through a merger you
know my early 20s I had the ability to
like go to another country and build out
part of their business that you know it
was kind of like doing a start-up but
within a company applying a business
model to new markets and in Asia you
know one of the things I got to do is
not only interact with the markets and
technical and trading level but also in
a regulatory level so I became like very
familiar with international law Japanese
Australian Singapore Hong Kong China and
just having like that kind of experience
at a really young age I think set me up
really well for what we're doing now
that company IPO in 2015 I took some
time off I learned about aetherium in
early 2016 in my previous career it was
like the humans losing on Wall Street to
computers yep right it's just computers
coming in and just like dominating and
when I read about a theorem I was just
like this is pretty much gonna happen
but to all other sectors of the
financial services stack so I just want
to be a part of it and then you know it
starts to look at exchanges start to
really study decentralized trading
blockchain how everything kind of fits
together and that we released the swap
protocol white paper with my co-founder
Don who's incredibly talented at like
you know synthesizing ideas and building
product and we released that white paper
went viral then we're on the map that's
awesome what do you think the biggest
things you learned ever to our I would
say the best thing I learned there
is not anything specific but more just
culture and how to actually behave and
what I mean by that is like we didn't
have the answers we never did you know
and when you're at the front lines of
the financial markets and
hyper-competitive it's a moving target
always trying to like come up with your
alpha and figure out your trades you
just have to figure it out there's no
one that's gonna kind of handhold you
through something like that and so just
kind of owning being able to actually
jump into a problem and figure it out
and you know and not only from a
mathematical perspective but also from
an intuitive perspective just having
that kind of ownership I think at a
young age was really incredible and also
that company's culture is very strong as
far as not prioritizing like ego
anything like that or politics with no
politics when that company was very flat
we had really good access to you know
the leaders in the company I eventually
was leader in the company and you know
still was around all the young guys all
time so I think that kind of flat non
hierarchical organization which you'd
probably find it like a bank if I spent
my 20s in a bank I don't think I would
be the same person at all
yeah it's super fascinating to how
nobody sat down and like hey here's rule
number one two three four or five of how
to act or whatever they just immersed
you in a culture right in kind of an
organizational structure and you just
naturally pick that stuff up through
experience rather than kind of
intentional learning so I think that's
that's how the strongest companies in
the world operate I think that's and
that's gonna be the future it's like I'm
even Ray Dalio you kind of just
transcribes his principles and gives you
a framework in which you operate and
that provides a framework in order to
answer some difficult some easy
questions because that the the thesis is
that in life you're gonna be presented
with the same questions over and over
and so just having like a very positive
framework around very intelligent and
down-to-earth people I think really
allowed that company to basically go
from nothing to the biggest trading
company in the world and what eight
years mm-hmm which is crazy on Wall
Street if you think about it yeah it is
pretty wild what uh what are one or two
things that you guys tried that
didn't work and you kind of took away a
lesson from yeah so made a big I
personally at that company made a big
push for the company to look more at
options trading so the company wasn't
like powerhouse and options trading this
is one of the things that I kind of
studied in college and I knew I knew
that the basics about and I have a
thesis about how we should actually be
trading them implying our system and my
thesis has to do with we already have
the technology and we already have the
ability to interact with financial
markets in microsecond level that's a
hard part all we need to figure out is
the pricing right we need to figure out
how to actually price these options and
figure out where how to price the the
Vall curve and when things move what
we're supposed to do and so I came in
with that these and I pushed really hard
and I think that we just didn't want to
devote the resources something like that
and I got a little bit of pushback on
that kind of plan and I think that was
actually probably the beginning of the
end of my career for too is that little
you know thing that I pushed for and I
and and I'm very self-directed person I
kind of want to want to decide my own
fate and I thought we can do it and it
wasn't giving the resources and I think
I decided maybe at that point I was
gonna leave absolutely and so you know
you go you figure out about aetherium
start looking at it's interesting to you
how do you go from oh this a theorem
things interesting to I want to build
air swap yeah that's I mean that that
was like a year and a half or maybe a
year apart so that's that's a good
question I think that first learning
about a theme I learned about it by
accident and a music festival from by
meaning jo zuban and a bunch of the
consensus people there's an April 2016
and at the time I was doing something
else and I had to kind of wind it down
but I was living in Los Angeles and
actually made friends with Brock peers
who lived in Venice at the time Brock
actually was one of the early people
that kind of introduced me to crypto you
know his his his fall from a little bit
of a fall from grace but I still you
know am loyal to him he introduced me to
some of the things and then and then I
just I kind of wound down my previous
project
and start to look at the space a little
a little more aggressively from LA but I
couldn't do it from LA because there
wasn't kind of the theorem community
there so I reconnected with consensus
started to hang out with them in New
York and I think a lot of the the
problem was breaking into the space was
that a lot of the people in blocking
that were kind of doing their own
projects in 2016 had been around for
like two or three years and they had a
name they had Twitter following I didn't
have any of that so I was like I
probably needs to just you know align
with the right people and I saw
consensus is a good opportunity to do
that when we actually started to do the
project when we wrote the white paper we
were never a consensus project we want
to convince this project until I have to
release the white paper and after you
know maybe even you know two months
before we did the token sale we came in
with our own capital Don and I had our
own you know previous successful career
so we came in as our own capital we
ended up doing it as a JV not as you
know their classic spoke structure or
whatever you want to call it and so we
were able to just operate outside of
consensus which I think for us made it a
lot better because we didn't really have
you know a hundred different people
telling us what they thought about a
project every day mm-hmm and so what was
the original idea was it how we know air
swap today was it something else and
it's kind of evolved over time you know
what goes into you know the ideas you
guys writing that original white paper
yeah so I think the I loved a ton to
answer your question in a short way but
in a long way basically we were reading
the message boards and trying to
understand what do people want in this
space was a kind of the first way I was
looking at it in 2016 and everyone
talked about decentralized exchange and
it was kind of like a hopping everyone
was talking about there are a few
implementations at the time and I was
looking at them and they were kind of
mostly using order book models and you
know I had a lot of experience with
order books trade on pretty much every
exchange in the world and I just kind of
decided hey we have this distributed
system distributed nodes with that are
processing the transactions order books
are inherently centralized or they exist
on one central server if you try to
distribute that you're going to run into
all sorts of problems and so we designed
a model that would became the swap
protocol and that is the correct design
for decentralized trading I think will
win in the long term and it basically
gets rid of the order book entirely of
decentralized so the way I think of
trade is you have five different
components of trade you have peer
discovery price discovery execution
clearing and custody okay you basically
go through those five you every time you
want to do trade you go through that
loop we managed to decentralize four out
of the five so we decentralize
everything except for peer discovery
peer discovery you find everyone in one
central place and then everything else
has done decentralized this past
peer-to-peer this doesn't end up being
subject to front-running it doesn't end
up having race conditions you don't have
to charge market makers for placing
orders and cancels which are all sorts
of different things that other designs
are running into and I think will make
it difficult for them to scale when they
start to get automated traders on their
platform and when things start to really
pick up it's going to be difficult for
them to scale we won't have that problem
we'll be able to always scale because we
kind of like designed it correctly from
the beginning got it yeah and into as
you're thinking through that why do you
think or why did you guys choose to not
decentralize the peer discovery is it
because you can't or is there some
regulatory reason or what was the
thought process is there because you got
four out of the five but what was that
last one I think it is it is possible to
decentralize the first one and I
actually don't think it would be super
difficult to do so and we might put on a
road map at some point but I think we
were just using the design where you
want to put in theory em you know you're
subject to scalability issues where you
basically can't just like throw
everything on chain you want to only put
the most important things on chain it's
similar similar to Bitcoin we have kind
of chain mechanisms in order to
communicate the state to the chain so we
basically designed something where the
part that was off chain was the peer
discovery and then you know in other
designs you basically have an off chain
order book which is which is centralized
because that's public it ends up being
subject to all sorts of issues later on
so you're just kind of trying to think
of what is the best way to do an off
chain on chain mechanism that doesn't
have these limitations and that's kind
of what we came up with got it and so
today the air swap product is what how
are people using it yeah so we released
the first version of the platform
network protocol in April of 2017 that
is basically designed for kind of more
automated traders to communicate to
manual maker so it's kind of just like a
quick checkout and the way we wanted to
do that with the quick checkout is to
basically integrated into dabs basically
have a widget that basically goes into
the apps we went into about 20 different
apps what we discovered is that you know
maybe the hard way that people aren't
really using taps the tokens are mainly
for speculative purposes at this point
and so we kind of have to go back to the
drawing board and we're like okay well
we want to think about how to design the
system but we also need to compete with
something like by Nance or coinbase
right which is difficult because we
can't do USD we can't do Bitcoin we have
longer transaction times that the UX is
just is just different you have to have
a wallet and knowledge of a wallet you
can't just come in with your bank
account and just like buy tokens so that
we were limited with by all these things
and we kind of decided to take a step
back and said how do we actually go
after the problem again and kind of the
full version of the system is basically
to allow a more communication style
interface and it's community generated
groups called spaces
we're rolling that out we just open this
up two days ago we're rolling it out
over the next few weeks and then
eventually we're going to have community
generated spaces and this is kind of
something that's at the intersection of
something like discord and the trading
project okay and so if I'm a user I can
come in I can get funds into the system
right and then I'm able to trade on this
decentralized exchange and I can also
chat or communicate with known or
unknown individuals right or how does
that chat part work yeah so you actually
don't
deposit funds in the system ever so
there's no custody or anything like that
you basically just come in with your
wallet and your signing transactions and
the the executions are occurring
peer-to-peer so that's kind of one of
the strengths of a decentralized
exchange key such as trading network
whatever we're calling it these days so
the thesis there and in the chat
interface is that there there are all
these other types of trades that you
might want to do you might not just want
to be communicating with the robot and
receiving trades but you might actually
want to get a better price you might
want to negotiate this is kind of how a
lot of different buckets of trading fall
into this something like the OTC markets
will fall under this and you know a lot
of people don't know this in crypto
because it's they're used to trading on
order blocks of trading on Finance but
most of what we trade in the world
happens peer-to-peer OTC yep both on
Wall Street and off Wall Street
everything every kind of transaction we
do every day is pure beer and so we're
designing for that kind of experience
but putting an interface on top that we
think is going to generate social
features accounts and we also have kyc
features as well so you could as you
know let's say for example is Morgan
Creek if you wanted to come onto the
system you're not going to trade against
random people you're gonna want to know
you're gonna want to kyc your clients
obviously for igitur reasons in that
part has been integrated into the
platform got it and so use also recently
released or started talking about
fluidity as well right and so you've got
air swap you've got air swap spaces and
then it looks like you guys are now also
going into the security token space so
how those related and kind of talk more
about fluidity and what the focus is
there yeah so we touched on this a
little bit earlier but fluidity is
basically our parent company we raise
our own funds and came into the joint
venture of consensus of air swap with
consensus so please actually our parent
company and we revealed it only about a
year after we had formed formed it so
we've formed it in 2017 we revealed it
at the fluidy summit earlier this year
which we're talking about earlier you
know our friend Marielle was debating
with that with Joe Lubin so we revealed
that the name of the company and also
the our commitment to bringing real
world assets on
to the blockchain that is obviously a
very hard problem and isn't something
that you can just first of all you have
to find an asset then you have to our
other thesis is that you need the right
framework in order to do this you need
the right standards that the industry is
going to subscribe to or else you know
if you just put list your house on like
a bulletin board right no one's gonna
and they don't no one knows where it is
or what or there has it any transparency
on it you're not gonna receive any
liquidity so we needed to figure out the
right asset we needed to figure out the
right framework and then we needed to
kind of come out with it and we actually
did that last week and that was probably
the most likes I've ever gotten on
anything I've ever published well
because what you guys announced was a 30
million dollar piece of real estate in
Manhattan right that is is getting
tokenized why you start with real estate
you know why that piece of property just
walk us through the thought process
yeah so we did like three or four months
a biz dev I think we talked to you guys
about a few different things you know
over over the months and trying to
figure out what we wanted to do and
really was about I think finding the
right partners we met this group
propellor
Todd lip yet is has like 20 years of
experience on Wall Street and structured
products and so he can just he just
understands that had a look at a deal
and see everything looks nuts and cranny
and and he also knows how to design a
deal that's actually good for investors
he has his own broker dealer he has his
own Fiat capability as a loan platform
and we knew how to do the blockchain
side of it when you had a crew take the
interests that we that they were going
to securitize and represent them as
tokens and then create a secondary
market for those for those tokens on air
swap which we can touch on a little bit
so we basically just found this really
good partnership and we were looking
through and trying to figure out they
have all these capability we have all
this capability
what should we focus on and the thesis
is that something if you look at the the
broad scheme of what can be tokenized
there can be something that's like a
highly liquid public security or there's
all these tail assets that
have not had that if you hold one of
them basically in order to get out of it
you have to have to repaper the
transaction you have to find a lawyer
you have to find a counterparty in that
that's also very difficult so it's just
the ability to streamline the the
secondary market process of the illiquid
assets our thesis is that we'll be
provide a ton of value whereas if you're
looking at a publicly traded security
like Apple or Facebook they already have
great financial markets for it and they
are they're already doing all the
disclosures there's all this regulatory
infrastructure in in place we're not
gonna be able to compete with that so it
just works right that the public markets
today actually work for a good amount of
people there's some that you know a
boxed out for different reasons but what
you guys are attacking is the markets
where they aren't working well right or
they could work better and so if you
start there that the bar to clear or
compete with is not very high yeah
exactly
got it okay and so walk us through the
actual structure of what you guys are
talkin izing right so my understanding
is that there's piece of real estate and
there's debt there's equity that there's
you know multiple components to this how
how did you guys structure it yeah so
it's so it's a basically what we
published was a framework called the two
token waterfall and what the two token
waterfall is it's a way to structure a
real estate or private security
transactions such that the the thesis is
if you structure it this way you will be
able to find liquidity and why is that
because token a replicates debt token B
replicates equity if you take both both
of these and add them together you
basically have the entire value of the
asset okay you're basically replicating
the entire financial stack of a real
estate asset and this can probably apply
to 90% of the assets in the world once
you get into the more complicated
structures you know si do si ellos that
stuff starts to get a little more
complicated but this you know mortgage
or building with you know 20 investors
you can and
a bank that has debt you can basically
replicate the entire financial stack of
that transaction so what does that
actually mean it means that when you
have a viewpoint on the price of the
asset you can immediately imply token a
price and you can immediately imply
token B price so what we're doing is
we're providing a plus B equals the
entire value of the asset and once we do
that you're giving transparency on the
entire value of the of the of the asset
and you're providing no arbitrage
pricing which will encourage traders to
come which will encourage the quiddity
got it and so do you think that the to
token waterfall works for real estate
but you know not equity or commodities
or currencies or do you think that this
too took a waterfall can pretty much
work for any asset that has both equity
debt in the capital stack yeah I think
it works for anything it's it's um it's
actually not specific to real estate we
reference real estate and in the white
paper it's for alternative investments
mm-hm so I can be something like private
equity or real estate or anything else
so the ideas for the framework to be
broad it's actually part of a wider
securitization framework that we are
working on and then we haven't released
yet so there is kind of our goal here is
to basically release a framework get a
landmark deal put the deal you know and
actually I can't these these are not
tied together the the the white paper is
not tied to the deal although it's a
framework you know for regulatory
reasons we can't have them tied together
exactly but we're essentially have this
deal we're putting it through something
that is similar to this framework and
then and then we're basically proving
the the thesis that there's going to be
an active secondary market and then we
can kind of expand out and cover the
majority of assets in the world got it
and let's talk about that secondary
market right because I think the one of
the knocks against security tokens today
is yeah sure the technology exists we
can go ahead we can tokenize things but
you know where's the liquidity right so
kind of you know what's your rebuttal to
that and where do you think we are
kind of where we going when it comes
that secondary trading or liquidity yeah
I think particularly air swap or
non-custodial trading platforms are
going to be really well suited to go
after this to go after the secondary
market why because in order to take
custody of an asset to think about it
you have to you have to basically have
trust right you have to have someone
else that's basically taking over the
asset for you and that's a highly
regulated event on Wall Street custody
is if you were going to start taking
custody of assets you have to have every
single asset approved as you start to go
into the long tail like we were talking
about before all the thousands of assets
but you know tens of thousands hundreds
of thousands it starts to get really
large regulatory burden on all of the
and every single asset you want to list
on your secondary market and so a
peer-to-peer noncustodial platform will
allow this technology to scale I'm also
going back to the idea of having OTC
more OGG style market all these assets
are kind of a liquid and so you're gonna
want a way to actually communicate with
someone you don't need to post it on an
order book and expect it to trade like
publicly traded high for high frequency
traded security just not gonna happen
that way really what you want is you
want an interface more similar to
something like you know eBay or
Craigslist where you're basically able
to have price discovery found in a
different way from an order book and so
I think that air swap is going to be
very uniquely positioned to go after
this market it's super interesting to we
think of a global investor base right
where you know there's a lot of hurdles
to jump over for all estate an
international investor who wants to
invest in us-based assets with auto
us-based exchange right and so I think
that there's an element of there's
problems that we know and there's
technology available today to solve
those problems but this base
specifically around decentralized
exchanges and the intersection with
security tokens feels like an area where
in the future we will create products
services or solve problems that
we don't even understand today right
totally agree and I think that's one of
the power of spaces that we're allowing
people to provide is relying them to
define their own training environments
so they can have their own kyc standards
they can have their own onboarding
process for you know let's say only only
want Japanese traders to be transacting
in the security or they're allowing it
to go cross-border between X Y Z country
that kind of controlled trading
environment we're allowing people to
create on air swap and the thesis is
that in order for something like this to
actually trade an order book basically
it assumes that everyone is identical
and everyone is exactly the same but
it's actually not true in real life um
and mostly for regulatory reasons yeah
no it is it's very analogous to you know
no one could have imagined
uber for example until there was the
advent of the smartphone with GPS and
you know touch screens all this kind of
stuff
when you look out 10 20 30 years what do
you think it's possible in this like
tokenized securities or other digital
securities world I can't look out 10 20
30 years that's that's a long time I
mean I think that the way I look at this
technology is you know the internet had
an incredible effect on humanity in
terms of business in terms of Education
allowing people to just communicate
anywhere in the world and decide how to
communicate right you decide how you
want to consume information everything
that we do with with money and and value
is top-down it's from the government
down we don't know it in the banks down
we don't kind of have a choice but this
is allowing for a peer-to-peer value
value transfer I mean obviously subject
to compliance I think that that kind of
society is going to be how that kind of
technology is gonna have a much broader
effect on society because money is so
core to our existence and the ability to
kind of participate in capital markets
and have you know freedom to participate
in and what you decide to participate in
I think that's gonna have really
profound impacts on society but I don't
think it's going to be like the Internet
where we have
it's going to be visual right it's it's
going to be it's just gonna gonna change
us in a Monro way like we're not gonna
be able to quantify I think blogging is
something that you know eventually that
the UX is going to be abstracted away
from everyone we're not going to be able
to actually realize that everything that
we're doing is kind of integrated it's
actually one of the things I love about
the theorem community is that all the
projects kind of you know interoperate
they figure out how to get their smart
contracts to match together so you
someone working on derivatives he is
someone working on compliance all these
different smart contacts can basically
interact with each other yeah and I
guess part of this is recreating
elements of Wall Street securities
markets you know except that we know and
then there's the imaginative part right
where can people figure out how to use
this technology and applied and and also
follow the rules what do you think today
in the securities did like digital
securities market is the main issues
holding this back from going you know I
don't know tens of millions maybe
hundreds of millions of market cap to
billions and hundreds of billions I
think we just need standards we need a
framework that basically first of all
the institutions are gonna buy into and
also the the general framework the
general investor is going to actually
buy answers I think we just need to
write frameworks we need to we need like
kind of the selling point of
tokenization to happen and I think
that'll probably happen over the next
six months to me if I look at this
technology I think that the next five
years are gonna be financed I think the
five years ago yet finance is going to
really get affected by this by this
technology the next five years after
that is going to be accounting because
basically once you have all every asset
on a blockchain there's essentially
nothing to account for and so you the
entire accounting industry kind of turns
into a GUI right where you're just
running a scrape and
everything is correct you know then the
next five years and you know this part
probably happens in parallel but I think
the legal industry the compliance
industry is going to change dramatically
I think automating compliance is going
to have tremendous of excellent society
because the way that laws are written
currently it's again it's top-down it's
the government says this is the way you
need to do things and people need to
follow that but and there is this like
kind of kind of you know level of trust
that happens or the the government maybe
trust you or doesn't trust you depending
on who you are to behave a certain way
but if if all of that is enforced in two
smart contracts and all of us are
engaging in this society where we know
that we're all following the rules I
think that allows us to do a lot more
things allows us to basically trim tax
in all these different ways and so I
think automated compliance I think
automated compliance is something that
people are not talking about enough yet
but I think they will very soon yeah I
mean look we we've gone as far say what
surprised of is if the SEC mandated it
right in terms of it actually makes
their job easier they gonna be proactive
rather than reactive part of it then
becomes who is trusted to write that
code right is it a decentralized team is
it the government themselves or
registrar body I think there's kind of a
lot of questions in the execution the
nuance is there but I generally believe
this technology couldn't solve one of
the fundamental issues that we see in
the existing markets and would be quite
powerful yeah I totally agree I mean
something like the accredited investor
checks you know can be enforced at the
at the blockchain level right you can
have a mechanism that basically looks at
you know either it if it's something
initially it'll be some central party
that basically puts it onto the Bob puts
your credit of SEO check onto the Box
chain but eventually it can just like
scrape your your earnings or something
like that you know and I think the
credit investor checks will change a lot
over the next two years that's another
topic may be worth going into but I
totally agree I think I think eventually
this stuff will be mandated
coding laws into smart conscience will
be mandated I don't know who's gonna do
that absolutely
what do you think it takes to get more
retail focused investors to switch from
investing in public markets and kind of
traditional stocks to tokenize secures
digital securities is it just user
experience and interfaces or do you
think there's some sort of like
inflection point that's event driven by
you know something in the market well
III think it goes back to kind of what
what you were saying before is that we
really don't know what this technology
is going to look like in three four or
five years you know a peer-to-peer
economy we don't really know we didn't
really we couldn't really predict Airbnb
but now Airbnb seems super obvious so we
don't really know what kind of
investments people are going to be able
to invest in or want to invest in so
it's kind of two sides it you don't we
don't know what the supply side is going
to be and we don't know what the demand
side is going to be we have some ideas
and some product ideas around that but
that's kind of our maybe our edge right
now just thinking about that a lot so I
don't know if I'm able to say yeah
absolutely okay and so what has been the
response from kind of the the global
audience right where do you see the most
interest in whether it's the the real
city you guys are doing now or just kind
of this move into the more kind of
security based assets is it continue
tell the difference between us versus
other regions of the world you know how
you just think about geography yeah I
mean everyone wants to invest in New
York real estate right so we've had a
tremendous amount of outreach from from
different people people reaching out to
us from around the world one of the
things we're kind of exploring right now
is a crowdfunding platform partnering
with a crowdfunding platform in
Singapore and maybe taking a portion of
it there because in Singapore they can
onboard Chinese they can onboard
European so I think making these global
products will allow them to proliferate
further you think about what what's
required for you
an international investor to invest in
Manhattan property at this day and age
other than doing it through a REIT or
something like that it's actually pretty
hard to to actually buy a property but
fractional izing and allowing anyone
well anyone subject to compliance to be
able to purchase I think you'll draw a
lot of international interest into this
market absolutely and part of me thinks
you know Wall Street's gonna be asleep
at the wheel and they're not gonna see
this stuff coming and there's gonna be a
whole disruption and then part of me
sees that they've got blockchain teams
and you know capital markets teams and
all stuff and they appear to be paying
attention where do you think the kind of
disruption occurs if any right do you
think that this is you know people sleep
at the wheel no matter if they know to
pay attention or not or do you think
that they're generally on top of it and
there will be kind of coexistence
between the legacy system and in this
new system yes I've thought about this a
lot because the way I think about it is
whether blockchain is going to be
transformative from the top down or from
the bottoms up the top town meaning you
know the bank's the government's aside
hey we're gonna put everything on a
blockchain and everything's gonna be
great or if it's bottoms up or basically
people are building this technology
they're they're layering on top they're
trying all these new things and
eventually it starts to pierce into the
there's some inflection point and
eventually that just Pierce's into what
the banks are doing I don't know what
the answer is I think it's going to be a
I think they're it's possible that there
there is a an event that really causes
this technology to proliferate but I
think like ultimately the banks are
getting wagged by the compliance
departments and so they you know you've
seen so many different ways that they've
been trying to get into crypto trying to
get into blockchain technology we have
conversations with you know a few a few
different banks it's been kind of
sometimes kind of frustrating where they
they're just always just thinking about
the you know they just can't take any
risk right and this is the reason why
you know virtue is so successful is
because
say we're able to move quickly and are
able to take Creston able to build these
platforms that the banks weren't able to
compete with so I think that I think the
Bottoms Up approach is more promising
but but I also think that in order for
this technology to really take off
especially on the tokenized securities
part and it's going to need
institutional adoption absolutely well
it just brings a level of legitimacy
right in kind of sophistication this
makes sense all right so let's do some
rapid fire questions here I'm going to
change it up just a little bit given
kind of what you're focused on on the
tokenize security side what do you think
the assets that need to get tokenized
that you haven't heard of yet which ones
would be the most intriguing to you such
a good question that you're speechless
you know one of one of the interesting
things that we were talking about
yesterday is different levels of the
entertainment stock which I personally
am very averse to the entertainment
industry because I'm from LA but I think
that there are different elements that
have tons of middlemen just involved in
taking a piece of the pie right where
the artist eventually isn't seeing
anything so being able to tokenize and
and represent that and value and you
know maybe royalties or something like
that I think there's a lot of promising
things there you know again there are so
many middlemen in that industry that you
would need it to you need that to come
from the top down I think you would need
the labels to you know invest in your
project in order to get that off the
ground
absolutely maybe enlist Kanye for that
one he seems to be a all over the the
tech and music scene right now is your
boy we'll see we'll see he's he's going
crazy on the internet lately
all right so other than air swapping
fluidity what do you think is the most
important company in crypto today I
think that the most important problem in
crypto is scalability and you're seeing
all these new platforms that are coming
out with all these unique ways to solve
scalability problem like Definity
and you're gonna see cosmos Enderman
coming out later I think like the hard
spoon later this year having ether men
having a second version of etherium that
has a different consensus mechanism I
think these are all gonna be super
interesting I think if he reads to
figure out how to scale because a lot of
competitions coming absolutely
competition might be good right
definitely I think it's it's I think
even the you know the price going down
and there being all this competition
coming to market I think has caused the
community to kind of rally around hey
you know we actually I have to get this
stuff done absolutely okay
what uh what's your one most
controversial thought in crypto if you
the one thought you have that a high
majority of other people would would
disagree with just don't want to offend
too many people with my answers whatever
one you just thought of that you don't
want to say say it nobody listens to
this anyways
you know I think the one thing that I've
never kind of understood is is how much
infighting there is in this community
like you know with what happened with
Bitcoin in 2017 or 16 I can't remember
now
17 17 you know people's careers base
care defined by what chain they support
and you know so it's kind of like these
technological upgrades and this
self-organizing community I think people
just need to be a little more patient
and supportive but you know I guess
that's not as fun on Twitter
yeah it's stuffy not as much fun and and
there's so much anonymity or
pseudonymity that goes on right that the
real identity is kind of lost
it's actually one of the things I don't
think I really talked about this
Facebook figured out early on right was
real identity actually increased the
quality of the content and so you know
in crypto I I don't think that everyone
should have to use their real identity
actually think there's a lot of
protections that can be provided by
anonymity pseudonymity etc but it is
interesting to see you know the
MySpace's of the world had all sorts of
pseudonymity anonymity Facebook said no
you have to use your real identity
higher quality content and ultimately
ended up being the winner I do wonder
what that impact would be on crypto if
everyone had to use a real identity we
have a lot of ideas around that
definitely for user-generated
communities I think identity is a huge
part of bakhtin that hasn't been
explored mm-hmm totally agree I think
that people have identity solutions but
they don't know how to use them mm-hmm
and so something like requiring
legitimacy on on a platform that people
actually use I think would provide a lot
of value
yeah it would be super easy to explore
all right you got a magic wand you can
wave it one time and change one
regulation or improve one regulation
what would it be I think the simplest
one is the credit investor rules I think
they're kind of stupid and outdated if
you think about it when I was 22 years
old I took my series 7
I became licensed
by FINRA to sell securities to the
public but I was an intern at an
investor so I couldn't buy them it's
pretty crazy
it's got changed yeah what do you think
the right uh rate framework would be I
think it's a combination of either
capital or some sort of education you
know if you know what you're doing you
should be able to participate and you
know a startup company that you believe
in yeah I'm a big fan that I think the
education one would be a bit harder to
implement obviously but but I do think
that it would be quite powerful and
actually you might get a more efficient
more safe market if you just have more
people educated totally agree right all
right so I end each podcast I let the
guest asked me one question what one
question would you like to ask you're
thinking so hard about this it's scaring
me I just have a few different will
break the rules you can ask - yeah I
guess where did where do you see this
going in two years two years so I think
a lot about the Bill Gates quote of you
know we overestimate two years
underestimate and ten and a digital
security side I completely agree we're
gonna get to a you know global
marketplace with you know kind of
compliance and law written to code all
the assets will be digitized etc I'm
actually pretty bearish on how far were
to get in two years as we've just looked
at it more and more I think part of the
problem is the user experience of the
key like or the core components isn't
there yet so one of it you know one of
the easy examples there is just when
Iced want to send you Bitcoin it's
actually pretty hard right and the
running joke is like you know everyone's
scared when they send it that it may
disappear
right because like I've got to make sure
I get your address perfectly right and
just that user experience sucks right
and so we're all the wackos that are
using this stuff early and it's fun and
it's cool
and we think we're really smart but
there's no way that mass adoption is
happening when I've got to send you know
Bitcoin to this random string of letters
and numbers right and so like that's a
really clear example of we gotta fix
that problem before mass adoption
happens and so if we got to do simple
stuff like that the odds that we're
gonna get to like buying and selling
digital securities in 24 months on a
global basis with code written into law
and like you know full harmony of
jurisdictions and all that kind of stuff
just I think there will be you know
examples or kind of early assets that
accomplish that we're not gonna have
like a highly liquid market place in my
opinion right so I think that you know
that's one thing now I don't think that
it takes ten years right so it's like
actually somewhere in between there and
so if you looked at it and said take you
know I don't know 70 trillion dollars of
assets right that are kind of tradable I
think in the u.s. then maybe I'm wrong
on a shirt but if that's true like fifty
percent of the assets are tokenized or
digitized right in the next ten years I
could see that right and just kind of
coexistence and and and there's kind of
this slow disruption of the existing
system like that wouldn't surprise me
yeah I actually totally agree with that
I think - I think Security's going
through any sort of kind of inflection
point I think it's probably at least two
years away one of the things I like to
think about and that I'm hopeful of is
that someone like Apple comes out with
you know hardware's wallet solution
that's basically integrated into your
device so everyone in the world
basically can sign and send transactions
there's like three companies that it
would be powerful for it'd be like a an
apple a Facebook and like maybe they can
want like an Amazon like a massive
retailer right like one of those three
companies a hardware provider some sort
of like social network identity provider
right and a retailer if one of them did
it I actually think it would force the
hand of everybody else right because
they don't want I don't know if Facebook
would want all of their users using
Amazon's wallet right so now a sudden
you push the pace of innovation
across the spectrum and everyone has to
create one and then somebody will come
around and they'll bundle them all
together and say you know hey here's one
wallet that interfaces or is it you know
interoperable with all these other
wallets and and we'll kind of enter this
whole cycle but but I think that that
first one is really important yeah and I
think Facebook's interesting because
they have a blockchain team from what I
heard it's their hat they're struggling
to find talent because you know a lot of
the young blockchain developers maybe
the ethos is a little bit at odds with
with Facebook and also you know I think
a lot of the young talented people won't
necessarily join Facebook at this point
so I think Facebook probably will go to
acquisition spree at some point to get
into blockchain in a serious way yeah I
mean I don't know for sure about the
engineer talent right like that wouldn't
surprise me I mean that's a narrative
that generally makes sense the one thing
that's interesting to me about Facebook
is they've got you know so their top
talent leading the team right so they
went and you know David Marcus Kevin
wheel exceptional you know Morgan Beller
they really have been thoughtful about
you know forgot put resources here let
make sure we put some of our best people
and so I'm interested to see you know
what they come out with but whatever
they launched they'll immediately be the
largest crypto company where they got
two billion users and so fall suddenly
gave everyone a digital wallet right or
something like that they just have more
users and and so I think that you know
that that's a pretty interesting world
of possibilities and so I'm cheering for
them too to do something that you know
kind of positively impacts the world and
you know drastically increases the
adoption of crypto me too
absolutely all right man this been super
fun thank you so much for coming we'll
have to do this again thank you
you